[Música]
[Aplausos]
soy una mujer que a lo largo de su vida
empezó a crecer que tener conciencia del
mundo que le rodea se dio cuenta de lo
lógico e ilógico se dio cuenta que por
lógica que con una fisionomía diferente
al del hombre se dio cuenta que tengo un
papel dentro de la sociedad como mujer
hija madre y esposa pero para la
sociedad en la que yo me desempeño como
mujer me dio un sinfín de oportunidades
me dijo angélica puede ser lo que tú
quieras estudiar el oficio que quieras
la carrera que tú quieras lo que tú
quieras el mundo es tuyo porque al fin
de cuentas estamos en un país que es
libre donde la mujer es libre de
desarrollarse en cualquier quehacer ya
sea político social o económico lo
lógico empezó cuando yo me echó un
clavado en estas oportunidades dije
voy a agarrar electrónica me gusta creo
que tengo la capacidad vamos cuando yo
me recibí como técnico en electrónica
ahí es donde empezó lo ilógico donde me
topé con realidad
cuando yo me fui a representar a las
máquinas como lo que solo técnico en
electrónica
de todas las máquinas a las que iban
todas me rechazaron los rechazos y
fracasos fueron de proporciones bíblicas
de todas ellas
dos me dijeron la voy a pensar y uno un
licenciado de contratación tuvo la
amabilidad de explicarme dijo angélica
siéntate sabes por qué no te puedo
contratar en primero porque eres mujer y
este es un trabajo para hombre en
segunda las mujeres se embarazan
menstrual este sus sentimientos no son
pues están medio locas
pues se enamoran muy fácil eso es lo que
me dijo es el licenciado a lo cual yo
nunca entendí y sigo hasta la fecha sin
entender puesto porque yo tengo la misma
capacidad que tengo piernas las dos
piernas las dos brazos los ojos
pienso hablo
lo único que me diferencia de él en el
sexo el género era lo único no había más
porque los dos tenemos un título
sufrimos igual lloramos igual nos
desvelamos igual entonces porque me
viene a decir que no puedo
al último ni siquiera me dio la
oportunidad de fracasar dijo no es que
no este trabajo es muy pensado si por
qué cargaron acá una escalera de 20
kilos de aluminio es pesado no voy a
poder no tengo esa capacidad es lo que
él me dijo
a lo que me di a la tarea de entender y
darme a mí misma esa confianza y ese
interés a demostrarle que no que no soy
una cosa bonita no soy una niña que está
en su casa y bonito y todo no me di a la
tarea de mostrarle que sí puedo que
tengo la capacidad
no sólo soy técnica en electrónica soy
competidora del levantamiento de pesas
soy campo en cambio a nivel nacional
mi último levantamiento fue de 130 kilos
hay mujeres que levantan el doble que yo
hay mujeres que son madres hijas o sea
profesionistas jonas y este para este
deporte
y no sólo físico sino mentalmente yo
nací hace un esfuerzo titánico por
ganarse un lugar un premio donde está lo
débil
no lo hay también usted es que la mujer
mexicana los que son madres de familia
son las primeras y últimas en levantarse
o sea la madre se levanta todos los días
más tempranos que el esposo para hacerle
de comer a los niños alistarlos a la
escuela las labores de la casa son muy
exigentes ellos no descansan si están
enferma lo siento mal pero tienen que
trabajar
dónde está lo de
y cuando se da el caso de que los dos
trabajen en el mismo horario laboral
el hombre siempre llega a aceptarse y
adelante les que diga estoy cansado y la
mujer que hace llega a barrer a ver que
sus hijos estén bien se hicieron la
tarea a planchar atender al esposo
entonces viene donde está el sexo débil
pidamos un esfuerzo más que los demás
y claro esto no es una guerra de sexos
debo de mencionar que me encantan los
hombres veo para ti
es en serio no nos veo
[Música]
y déjenme decirles que también los
hombres sufren de violencia de género
pero con mágica ustedes díganme cuántos
hombres enfermeros
o secretarios
sin pensar mal
poco es verdad entonces de qué se trata
se supone que somos un país lleno de
oportunidades que te dicen o algo que tú
quieras y el último siempre no o sea que
es de dientes para jugar ahora aquí
estamos jugando
en qué se trata
se trata de que somos libres que tenemos
un derecho como individuos dentro de
esta sociedad y que debemos reclamarlo
se trata de que si tú me das una
oportunidad de desarrollarme de lo que
soy déjame fijamente talo y así el
fracaso pues es mi problema y al final
de cuentas no hay fracaso malo porque
eso nos demuestra de qué estamos hechos
y lo vamos a mejorar vamos a ver que
estamos hechos y con la convicción y
entereza lo vamos a lograr vamos a
demostrarles que yo tengo un valor que
tengo un valor dentro de la sociedad que
nadie me dio yo sola les voy a demostrar
que sí puedo que no soy un sexo débil
nada y nadie sobre la faz de la tierra
te debe decir que no pueden negar ese
derecho tan preciado que tenemos nadie
es este pecado debería hacer penitencia
debería ser porque somos libres somos
libres de hacer lo que nosotros queramos
y como yo siempre digo y este es mi lema
si no hay un camino fábrica te lo así
como se puede claro no es fácil pero no
imposible si se puede
gracias